good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight things change
fast but it's our job to keep track
it wasn't so long ago that our taste
making class had decided that andrew
cuomo of new york was the single
greatest governor in american history
reporters who covered him didn't so much
ask cuomo questions they
swooned blushing in his presence people
who pass out emmys
gave andrew cuomo an award just for
holding press conferences
over on cnn jeff zucker handed the
governor a recurring spot on his little
brother's tv
show yes andrew cuomo is quite a bit
taller than chris cuomo
for a moment there andrew cuomo was the
man
they told us he was a steely mixture of
abraham lincoln and paulie walnuts
he was just what america needed in
crisis
in case you think we're overstating the
magnitude of the hype around
andrew cuomo if you have a minute look
up the exchange from last may between
robert de niro and stephen colbert
two formerly talented entertainers
who've been warped beyond recognition
bipartisan bitterness
watch as they wax pornographic about the
awesomeness the singular awesomeness of
andrew cuomo
at one point colbert loses all control
and describes cuomo as the leader quote
the world deserves andrew cuomo governor
of the world
it's hilarious at this point it's
painful to watch though because no one
seems to like andrew cuomo anymore
he's been me too for saying naughty
things to women
even andrew cuomo's former friends are
treating him like harvey weinstein
cuomo was hired in fact one of
weinstein's defense lawyers
at this point it's hard to imagine that
andrew cuomo will be governor of new
york for much longer
no one who knows andrew cuomo could be
shocked by any of this
for more than a decade cuomo has been an
awful governor of new york for reasons
that have nothing to do with sexual
harassment though that's bad too
three years ago cuomo's closest aide
someone he described as like a brother
went to federal prison for six years for
bribery last year cuomo famously caused
the lonely deaths of thousands of
elderly new yorkers locked away in
nursing homes
so from day one andrew cuomo has been a
disaster for the state of new york and
yet
the democratic establishment has
relentlessly defended him why have they
done this
well because he helped them maintain
what they want most of all and that is
power
nothing has made elected democrats more
powerful than the kovid pandemic
they began as politicians lockdowns made
them
god andrew cuomo understood the power of
kovid
immediately as early as last april cuomo
declared that coronal law would last
forever
i don't think we get back to normal he
said i think we get to a
new normal now at the time there was no
vactine for the coronavirus so many
people reluctantly
accepted cuomo's prediction okay a new
normal but 11 months later we have
multiple coronavirus vaccines
infection rates are falling along with
deaths and yet the message from the
democratic establishment has not changed
your life is never going back to normal
we aren't surrendering our power over
you
or your children it's permanent now the
media rather than question this
amplified the message and they do it for
their own reasons when democratic
politicians become more powerful so do
their spokesman
in the news media stop expecting life to
go back to normal next year
read a new york times piece from
september a month later the paper ran a
story with this headline
the first coveted vaccine will not make
life normal again
now not everyone believed that of course
because it's ridiculous the whole point
of the vaccine was to bring life back to
normal
but the fact that people might live
normal lives deeply bothers the new york
times
go to their website today and you will
find this quote covet 19 the u.s is
edging toward normal
alarming some officials yes some
officials are alarmed you might be able
to go outside without getting their
approval first
they're worried your kids might get an
education you'll notice the times
interviewed
officials rather than parents if the new
york times had talked to parents
here's what they might have heard this
is the second largest school district in
the country
they need to figure it out they're out
of time science
facts all states that these kids need to
be in school
these kids are in mental distress they
have to go back to school can't
take one more day of forcing them to sit
in front of zoom
when they're not learning and they're
hating school and they're depressed
they're dejected their grades are
falling they're regressing
it's disgusting we're fighting for our
rights to go back to school
because science says that it's safe and
the utla won't let us
kids are depressed and dejected and they
are regressing that's the word from a
mother in los angeles
people who've paid attention have known
that for a long time knew it was
happening
but a new analysis by fair health shows
just how destructive the lockdowns have
been
worse than you thought now the survey
didn't rely
on questions they asked people instead
it looked at the data
billions of health care records and
insurance claims and here's the top line
conclusion of the study quote
the covid19 pandemic has had a profound
impact on mental health particularly
that of young people school closures
having to learn remotely and isolating
from friends due to social distancing
have been sources of stress and
loneliness
well that's bad how bad is it here's how
bad it is
among children aged 13 to 18 teenagers
insurance claims for intentional
self-harm were up 90
in march of 2020 compared to the
previous year the next month
in april self-harm cases rose by nearly
100 percent
claims for medical help related to drug
overdoses went up 95
in march and then to 113 percent in
april
and those numbers remained elevated
through the fall
why why was this happening mental
illness caused by coronavirus lockdowns
quote
for the age group 13 to 18 in april 2020
insurance claims for generalized anxiety
disorder increased
93.6 percent as a percentage of all
medical claims
in april of 2019 major depressive
disorder claims increased 83.9 percent
in adjustment disorder claims by 89.7
percent
end quote thanks to the chronovirus
lockdowns children are 10 times more
likely to die from suicide
than from the coronavirus they're meant
to be protected from
so that is the new normal that andrew
cuomo and the new york times are working
to make permanent in this country
and if the teachers unions have their
way your child may die of a drug od
before going back to school
and if you complain about that you're a
white supremacist
that was the explicit message yesterday
from the president of los angeles
teachers union watch
some voices are being allowed to speak
louder than
others we have to call out the privilege
behind the largely white
wealthy parents driving the push for
a rushed return their experience of this
pandemic is not our students family's
experiences
so the woman you just heard is called
cecily my art cruz
the first thing you'll find on her
official biography is the fact that she
is quote the first woman of color in the
union's 50-year history
so cecily mayard cruz believes her skin
color is a job
qualification somehow maybe the most
important one she has
why is she saying this she's hoping you
won't notice that she's incompetent or
that her positions don't make any sense
at all
cecily mayar cruz is telling us that
poor families benefit
most from closing public schools but of
course the opposite is true
poor families need their kids back in
school more than anyone does because
they don't have alternatives
most of the quote white wealthy parents
she is attacking
don't use the public schools precisely
because they don't want their kids
anywhere near lazy mediocrities like
cecily my art cruz
parents with privilege have options and
they run away
now who are these privileged people
we're talking about well they're people
like matt meyer the head of the berkeley
teachers union
meyer would tell you if you talk to him
that he's a progressive like so many
other pasty middle-aged trustefarians
he's got earrings and blonde dreadlocks
but the truth is matt meyer doesn't want
his daughter around cecily my art cruise
either at
all so he sends her to private school
and we know this not because the new
york times did an expose on it that
maybe they should given that matt meyer
is the personification of the white
privilege they're so worried about
no we know this instead because an
anonymous group of parents called
gorilla moms
photographed matt meyer dropping his
child off at private school
here's that same matt meyer back in
january insisting that your children
can't go back to school because they
can't be trusted to keep their masks on
real life children do not keep their
mass on they do not keep distance from
each other or their teachers
given the realities of working with real
children in person
we need to account for the inevitable
lapses in risk mitigation practices
by choosing a standard of lower
transmission for reopening
risk mitigation blah blah blah what
meyer doesn't mention is that there is
virtually no risk to anyone of sending
children back to school and there never
has been the science couldn't be clear
and that's why when he doesn't think
you're watching matt meyer makes certain
his
own child gets the in-person instruction
she needs he doesn't want her growing up
to be a drug addict
like your kids